[Musik]
ein spaziergang hesketh ben war mit
stock noch gut zu fuß sucht mit einem
freund das grab von danny vor kurzem
noch haben sie telefoniert dann kam die
meldung danny ist tot
er hatte sich mit corona infiziert einer
von 41 freunden bekannten die huskies in
den vergangenen sechs monaten verloren
hat die einschläge kommen immer näher
vor zwei wochen ist dann mein bruder
gestorben
es ist noch nicht klar ob das corona war
wie bei anderen augen ob es eine rolle
spielt dass er schwarz war es macht mir
eine heidenangst ich habe kinder viele
enge freunde und bekannte der tod meines
bruders trifft kann das grab seines
freundes nicht finden
zur beerdigung des corona opfers war nur
die engste familie erlaubt herr scott
konnte nicht abschied nehmen wo sie die
toten jedoch normalerweise mit risiken
festen feiern
41 menschen verloren alle schwarz ist
auf einen
es kann doch nicht sein dass schwarze
und asiatischstämmigen briten deutlich
häufiger sterben daher kommt die
verbitterung die angst die sorge vor
allem da die zweite corona welle und
wohl spätestens ende oktober trifft das
ist meine lieben trifft das versteht man
doch im nord londoner stadtteil haring
gay ist heft bekannt wie ein bunter hund
der 62 jährige rentner hat als dozent an
der nahen hochschule gearbeitet
trainiert das örtliche basketball team
leistet freiwilligenarbeit wo er kann
aktuell in einer tafel für bedürftige
denn corona trifft hätte stadtviertel
doppelt die ersten die krank werden die
ersten die entlassen werden
meine tochter ist in kurzarbeit einer
meiner söhne auch er ist busfahrer einer
der wichtigen berufe in der krise an
vorderster front in kontakt mit vielen
menschen
das hat meine frau wirklich getroffen
wird beide machen uns große sorgen dass
kurzarbeiter programm läuft jetzt aus
ökonomen prophezeien eine
entlassungswelle mediziner die zweite
virus welle wird diese ethnische
minderheiten wieder so hart treffen
ein report der staatlichen
gesundheitsbehörde listet schon im juni
gründe für die vielen toten unter
schwarzen und asiatischstämmigen briten
auf als unverzichtbare arbeitskräfte in
krankenhäusern lebensmittelmärkten als
bus oder taxi fahrer seien sie den virus
stärker ausgesetzt
dazu kämen oft beengte wohnverhältnisse
risikofaktoren wie diabetes oder
übergewicht seien weiter verbreitet es
ist die oberste pflicht jeder regierung
alle zu schützen die im land leben alle
die dort arbeiten und dass die regierung
wirklich gar nichts getan hat trotz der
klaren empfehlungen der
gesundheitsbehörde im juni ist mehr als
beunruhigend
vielleicht besser wenn die regierung
nichts tut solchen sport habe sich boris
johnson verdient findet eine wachsende
zahl von kritikern mal muss sich der
premier entschuldigen weil er selbst
nicht mehr weiß welche regeln wo im land
gelten was ihnen mit vielen landsleuten
verbindet die noch immer zitat johnson
auf das weltbeste corona testsystem
waren bereit zehn milliarden euro
investiert ein kleiner fehler in einer
excel tabelle und das system bricht
zusammen das nennen viele
intergalaktischen kompetent in systemen
gehen zehntausende ergebnisse verloren
in corona hochburgen gibt es zeitweise
nirgendwo test oder es staut sich in
laboren man etwa studenten die in den
ferien geholfen haben zurück an die unis
sollen gegen den rat der experten mit
dem segen der regierung massenhaft
kehren junge menschen zurück in die
wohnheime viel party fiel koran 50 unis
gibt es mittlerweile 4000 fälle cluster
alarm
zehntausende studenten befinden sich im
lock down
[Musik]
großbritannien beklagt die meisten
corona toten in europa
die wirtschaft wurde am härtesten
getroffenen städte wie etwa in london
verweisen
denn wer kann der flieht
wird zur krisen gewinnerin wie ihrer sap
sie hat sich einen lebenstraum erfüllt
ein haus im grünen diesen schritt
gemacht zu haben ein unglaubliches
gefühl erzählt sie nur weg von der alten
heimat london corona macht es möglich
es fühlt sich gut ich fühle mich sicher
dazu viel frische luft so viel platz
nicht mehr dicht an dicht im bus und
u-bahn eingezwängt sein zu müssen
hier kann man alles zu fuß erreichen und
es gibt kaum corona infektion my home is
my castle die immobilienpreise im
ostenglischen wörtchen hales word sind
niedrig das ganze leben viel günstiger
doch die londoner gehälter bleiben iras
und ihr mann den arbeiten in der
tech-branche
da braucht es nur eins ordentlich bums
beim internetanschluss iras produziert
animationsfilmer etwa für disney die
gartenhütte ist zum home office
ausgebaut kurze video anrufe in die
zentrale ab und zu für einen tag nach
london zwei zugstunden entfernt das
größte glück für mich ist dass wir immer
zusammen frühstücken und abendessen
können gemeinsam am tisch sitzen
das gab es in london nie übers alter
schreibtisch in ihrer firma jellyfish
bleibt leer
1,6 millionen londoner haben während des
lok downs von außerhalb gearbeitet wie
viele den schritt für immer wagen ist
unklar
doch die nachfrage von städtern nach
immobilien im grünen hat sich fast
verdreifacht
raus nur weg das blatt für heskey und
ken unerreichbar
weil unbezahlbar corona treffen eben
nicht alle gleich das macht mich wütend
traurig ich frage mich ist es das noch
wert ich wünschte mir ich könnte
woanders hingehen wo ich mich willkommen
führen würde
wir sehen wie die korona fallzahlen
wieder deutlich ansteigen
für die menschen um mich herum verheißt
die zukunft nichts gutes
zu viele seien schon jetzt gegangen da
kann man ergänzt herz bis zum abschied
nicht mehr optimismus erwarten
[Musik]